- Aux Canadiens qui comptent
leur sous et craignent
une récession, l'énoncé
économique offre un peu
de répit et un avertissement.
(applaudissements)
La hausse vertigineuse
du coût de la vie semble
guider le gouvernement.
Le terme "inflation" apparaît
dans le document à 115 reprises.
CHRYSTIA FREELAND,
ministre fédérale des Finances
- Pour les Canadiens
pour qui c'est difficile
à la caisse ou lorsqu'ils font
le plein, l'inflation
est encore trop élevée.
- Pour aider les plus
vulnérables, Ottawa prolonge
l'Allocation canadienne
aux travailleurs et enverra
des chèques plus souvent,
au lieu de le faire seulement
une seule fois par année :
trois chèques de 714 $ pour
les travailleurs célibataires,
trois chèques de 1200 $
pour les familles.
Pour les jeunes, c'est
la fin des taux d'intérêt
sur les prêts étudiants,
ce quieueur fera économiser
en moyenne 410 $ par année.
- Nous comprenons
qu'il y a beaucoup
inincertitudes économiques
dans le monde et que la réalité
est qu'aujourd'hui,l'économie ce
est en train de ralentir.
- Pour faire face à une possible
récession, la ministre dégage
un milliard de dollars
pour préparer une réforme
de l'assurance-emploi
et prévoit de nouvelles
mesures pour fouetter
la croissance économique :
un nouveau Fonds de croissance
du Canada, un crédit d'impôt
de 30 % pour les technologies
vertes et 250 millions sur 5 ans
pour former les travailleurs
du secteur pétrolier
à un emploi plus vert.
En plus de ces carottes,
la ministre brandit aussi
un bâton : une nouvelle taxe de
2 % sur le rachat d'actions par
les sociétés, afin de les forcer
à réinvestir leurs profits
dans leurs travailleurs
et leur entreprise.
MARIO SECCARECCIA, prof. science
économique, Université d'Ottaa
- Par rapport à d'autres pays
comme les États-Unis, le Canada
vraiment, c'est un des pays
les plus faibles au niauau
des investissement privés.
- Le gouvernement Trudeau
met également de côté jusqu'à
un milliard de dollars pourla rs
dévastées par l'ouragan Fiona.
Dans un énoncé marqué
par l'incertitude économique,
le gouvernement Trudeau a caché
une surprise de taille.
Pour la première fois depuis
son élection, il ose prédire
un retour à l'équilibre,
un premier surpl b budgétaire
d'ici 6 ans, si tout va bien.
Malgré tout, l'opposition
reste sur sa faim.
GABRIEL STMAMARIE, porte-parole
du BQ en matière de finances
- C'est du réchauffé.
Peut-être comme le pâté chino,,
le réchauffé goûte meilleur,
mais il y a rien de... il y a
rien de nouveau dans l'énoncé.J,
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Le gouvernement, qui a promis
d'être là pour les gens,
a tourné le dos aux gens
pour le coût de chauffage,
le coût d'épicerie,
qui continuent d'augmenter.
PIERRE POILIEVRE, chef de
l'opposition officielle, Ottawa
- ce stratagème inflationniste
augmente les taxes sur le
chauffage, lssssence et les
épiceries. Et nous allons voter
contre ce stratagème
inflationniste.
(applaudissements)
- Chrystia Freeland se livre
à un exercice d'équilibre :
contrôler l'inflatiototout
en stimulant l'économie, entre
l'aide aux plus vulnérables
et la prudence fiscale,
le gouvernement marche ainsi
sur un fil de r r économique,
mais aussi politique.
Ici Christian Noël,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw